uh hi everyone welcome to itcs
2021 the 12th innovations in theoretical
computer science conference
um i'm the pc chair james lee
um see
uh so i mean it's it's uh it's great
that we're all able to get together
despite the uh what's going on in the
rest of the world
um the rest of the world the entire
world
uh i'm excited about the program um
uh i think this provides us uh actually
an opportunity
to sort of explore the ways of uh
broadening participation in tcs
uh like by their nature
uh attendance at conferences like this
are limited to a
small fraction of the global tcs
community
so i hope that we can learn from this
event
um in ways that sort of reshapes uh even
our in-person conferences
going forward uh let me very briefly
thank the program committee for all
their hard work
uh um the itcs steering committee
got some comet for helping to organize
the technical aspects
of a virtual conference and the
assignment institute
and their staff for hosting the event
um i think briefly
tom uh tom gur has some remarks to make
about
uh about safety oc
yes let me see if i can show my screen
um okay um can you see the slide
okay good so we just want to say uh one
minute about
safe dlc um so in a sentence
safety c is a group of volunteers that
perform
primarily to combat harassment and to
keep
a friendly and inclusive environment
and um it's great to say that idcs is
strongly committed to
follow these principles and that
essentially means we want to keep
the atmosphere as friendly as inclusive
as possible and not tolerate any
harassment or discrimination of any
songs
so um for each conference we have a few
representatives
um in this uh idcs
it's uh mega guard anna caroline and
myself
and what i want to ask of you is that if
there is any problem at all
whatsoever please contact us and we will
do everything within our to help
and if you want more information you can
find it at the link below which is
safetyoc.org thank you
yeah thanks tom uh that information is
also
uh at the program at the top of the
program
where you can also find the sort of the
schedule
together with the full videos uh that
people have recorded ahead of time
preliminary proceedings and uh and links
to the slack channel so every paper has
a
channel i encourage the authors to check
um
to check those channels to see if
there's a discussion about their paper
that they can participate in
uh and then the the gather time map
which
if you registered you received an email
about it but you can also access it from
the program page
that's open all day including for a
while after the conference if you want
to continue conversing with people
if you are graduating in the near future
or you've recently graduated
there might still be some space left in
the graduating bid session tomorrow
morning
uh if you're interested in participating
in that you should contact
uh galton uh again his email is on the
program
uh so you can find it uh
and then just uh briefly want to say
this is an experiment
uh so it's a good idea while you're
participating in the conference to think
about what works and what doesn't
and we'll send out forms to collect
feedback
once the conference is over um and then
if you're interested in
discussing or hearing more about the
logistics
of the of the program and and
[Music]
sort of forming a virtual conference on
on relatively short notice
then the business meeting is this
afternoon at 3 30
local time which is pacific time my
local time
um okay with that said
i think there is not much left to say
right now
so uh the first session starts in a few
minutes i encourage
everyone to the extent possible to have
their cameras on
so that everything feels more personal
helps with the sense of community uh and
so
uh yeah so i guess in about seven or
eight minutes
uh ilet will chair the first session of
the conference
um welcome again and hopefully
everything
uh goes well